طبعا ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف مستشار هيئه
الفضاء السعوديه الدكتور هيثم التويجري
الدكتور صبحك الله بالخير يعني اليوم هل
نستطيع ان نفرح الان بهذه التجربه ونقول
هي تتويج لعمل وطموح ام انه لا والله نحط
عيننا على القادم والقادم اكثر ربما
في
البدايه صباح الورد
لازم يعني يرفع خاصه الشكر والعظيم
والعرسان لمقام خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان والصحت
وصاحب السمو
الامير محمد بن سلمان
العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء لانهم الداعمين
الكبراء اللي دعموا هيئه السعوديه للفضاء
والاطلاق هذا البرنامج
اجابه السؤال يعني طبعا هذه
رحله تاريخيه
يعني زي ما تفضلتوا بوجود رائد الفضاء
منطلقين لكن
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله القادم اعظم
طيب دكتور ماذا يعني بالنسبه للسعوديه
والسعوديين بانه اول عربيه ستطا يعني او
تذهب الى الفضاء هي سعوديه ماذا يعني هذا
الكلام للمراه السعوديه للسعوديه في هذه
المرحله من تاريخها وكل التغييرات اللي
حصلت مؤخرا
في الحقيقه يعني كون
ريانه راح تطلع وتكون ان شاء الله او
الرائده قضاء عربيه مسلمه يعني هذا طبعا
فخر كبير
المملكه بحيث انها
تظهر امام العالم
مدى اهتمامنا حنا بالمراه واهتمامنا في
دور المراه في المجتمع وكيف انه ممكن تكون
هي يعني رائده يعني زي ما يقولون رول مودل
للجيل القادم هل هل نعتبر القرني وبرناوي
هم بدايه الغيث وانه القادم اكثر يتم
تجهيز رواد فضاء قادمين في المستقبل
ان شاء الله يعني القادم افضل واعظم ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لمستشار
هيئه السعوديه للفضاء الدكتور هيثم تويجري
يبدو ان السعوديه لن يكتفوا بالاغنيه فوق
هام السحب وربما في الفضاء كمان باذن الله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات